[Music]
on this friday night the cascading
effects of the u.s
president testing positive for covid19
the consequences for the campaign what
happens if he becomes incapacitated
and will this serve as a wake-up call he
could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
plus the potential super spreader event
parts of ontario clamp down the new
restrictions and the plan to clear
the testing backlog and gut wrenching
grief
joyce eshequan's family escalate their
fight for justice
global national with donna friesen
there have been plenty of historic
events at the home of the u.s president
but nothing
like this inside the white house
president donald trump and his wife
melania spent the day in self-isolation
both of them infected with the virus
that has killed more than one million
people
around the world good evening and thanks
for joining us just 32 days before the
presidential election and there is
anxiety and
uncertainty late today the president was
seen for the first time since his
diagnosis giving a thumbs up
and boarding marine one which took him
to walter reed medical center in
maryland
the white house says it's out of an
abundance of caution
before he left trump recorded a short
message
i think i'm doing very well but we're
going to make sure that things work out
the first lady is doing very well
the white house says his symptoms are
mild but he does have a fever
he is 74 overweight and that puts him at
higher risk
he announced his positive test in a
tweet hours after the news broke that
one of his trusted advisors and long
time
senior aides hope hicks developed
symptoms and tested positive on thursday
morning
both she and trump were in close contact
with many people this week rarely
wearing a mask and it's having a
cascading effect not just on his
campaign but on senior levels of
government
the vice president mike pence and his
wife said they tested negative today
so has house speaker nancy pelosi and a
whole lot of other senior people
including the attorney general and the
secretary of state
the chair of the republican national
committee is positive though and many
others are still waiting for test
results
trump was on stage with his rival joe
biden on tuesday at the debate
though they stayed apart and did not
shake hands biden said today he's taken
two tests and he is negative
so is his wife he continued his campaign
today
sending his best wishes to the president
and first lady and making a plea for
everyone to wear a mask
in public we can save more than 100
000 american lives in the next hundred
days alone
if everyone wore a mask in public
jackson prescott joins me from
washington jackson trump going from home
to the hospital the day after he's
diagnosed suggests his symptoms are
more than just mild what can you tell us
it's not just that donna is the fact
that the president according to white
house doctors was given an experimental
antibody therapy today a high dose of
that experimental therapy
based on compassionate grounds which
means it was essentially released to
somebody
who would not typically have access to a
non-approved medication
all of this suggests things may be more
serious than the white house is letting
on there's a tremendous amount of
concern tonight
but the fact that the president walked
to that helicopter to be airlifted to
walter reed medical center does suggest
at least for now
he's doing okay president donald trump
may have already been feeling unwell as
he returned from a private fundraiser
thursday night
hours later he revealed his positive
diagnosis in a tweet
tonight the first lady and i tested
positive for covid19 he wrote
we will begin our quarantine and
recovery process immediately
we will get through this together they
remain in good spirits
the president does have mild symptoms
trump's chief of staff appeared without
a mask to warn of more cases likely to
come
i fully expect that as this virus
continues to go on
other people in the white house will
certainly
have a positive test result soon after
the president missed a planned phone
call with governors about the kovit 19
response
trump and the first family suspended all
future in-person campaigning
vice president mike pence who would have
to assume the duties of the president
should trump's condition worsen
will still travel to events often those
who go on to develop severe disease
the critical period is around 10-12 days
um
since this symptom onset um and and so
so that's
the period uh you know we are all all
hoping
will pass uneventfully the white house
says it learned
trump's aid hope hicks was positive just
as the president departed for a private
fundraiser thursday night
but they let trump continue on to the
event where he may have unknowingly
exposed high paying donors
it was deemed safe for the president to
go he's socially distanced it was an
outdoor event and it was deemed safe
by white house operations given the
window for infection
trump may have been contagious during
tuesday's presidential debate
it must make a big difference where
trump's family defied
mask requirements and sat barefaced in
the crowd
as the president mocked his rival joe
biden over the issue of face masks
every time you see him he's got a mask
he could be speaking 200 feet away from
it he shows up with the biggest mask
i've ever seen
biden has since tested negative but just
like trump
a cluster of people who were at a white
house event last saturday for the new
supreme court nominee
have now tested positive including the
president of the university of notre
dame
and utah republican senator mike lee
seen here
hugging other masculist attendees in the
rose garden
jackson trump's justification for rarely
wearing a mask was that most people who
come into close contact with him or
tested
first we know they use rapid tests at
the white house what are experts saying
about that strategy tonight
you know the medical experts i spoke
with today say it's great that somebody
like trump who comes into contact with a
lot of people is tested frequently
but that's just one part of the strategy
they say he still needs to adopt
things like mask wearing and social
distancing and proper ventilation in the
rooms that he's
in really they say that the testing that
he's been undergoing may have actually
created a false
sense of security here and anecdotally
you certainly hear that from people who
work in and around the white house
that mask wearing just has not been
commonplace inside that bubble that
there's been a lot of confidence that
testing alone would keep the virus at
bay
okay jackson proskow in washington
thanks well there is a protocol in place
if the u.s president
becomes incapacitated and can't carry
out his duties the u.s
constitution in the 25th amendment makes
clear the vice president assumes the
powers and duties if the president is
unable to do so
because of death resignation or
inability section 3 allows the president
to
transfer power voluntarily to the vice
president even for a few hours
if that's necessary and section 4
addresses a more complex issue when a
president
is incapable or unwilling to declare his
incapacity
then the vice president and a majority
of cabinet would declare the president
unable to carry out his duties and power
would immediately transfer to the vice
president
and if both the president and the vice
president are incapacitated then house
speaker nancy pelosi
is next in line the white house did say
today the president remains
fully in charge anyone who came into
close contact with him in the past few
days
is at risk and that is a lot of people
as jeff semple explains contact tracers
have their work
cut out for them tracing the contacts of
anyone with covid 19 is a challenge
but perhaps no one more so than the
president of the united states
during a campaign the network of people
that
that he's with and and their networks
is enormous donald trump had a busy week
but reports say he didn't start feeling
sick until
late thursday the average incubation
period is about five days so you're
exposed to someone
and then five days later they can have
symptoms that means
trump may have become infected last
weekend on saturday he announced his
supreme court pick in the rose garden in
front of a crowd of 200 people
at least two of whom including senator
mike lee have also since tested positive
for covid19
on sunday trump held a socially
distanced press conference
and that evening hosted an indoor
reception for military families
this white house video shows most
including the president not wearing a
mask
nor did trump wear a mask or socially
distance on monday
when he hosted some american automakers
to celebrate their latest truck
trump has previously said that all
guests are tested before they get near
him
but experts warn those rapid tests
aren't always reliable
and that's why you know all things being
equal if there's any doubt in your mind
really just wear the mask by tuesday's
presidential debate
experts say it's possible trump was
already contagious
24 to 48 hours before you develop
symptoms you can still infect others
which is what makes this virus so
difficult to control he and his
presidential opponent
spent over an hour shouting over each
other albeit at a distance
and joe biden has since tested negative
but the next day
trump traveled to minnesota for a rally
attended by
thousands most mask-less and he attended
a closed-door fundraiser at a private
home
he traveled there with his aide hope
hicks she started feeling sick that
night
and tested positive the next day trump
traveled to new jersey thursday
afternoon
for another fundraiser this could lead
to a significant outbreak
new jersey's governor has asked anyone
who attended the events
to self-quarantine contact tracers say
their one advantage in this case
anyone who might have had contact with a
contagious donald trump
has surely heard about it by now
president trump as a super spreader
is um an unexpected story with
32 days to go jeff semple global news
if there is one person who knows what
president trump is going through it is
british prime minister boris johnson
the 56 year old had covid19 in march his
symptoms were so severe at one point he
ended up in intensive care for three
days
fighting for his life he did recover and
he named his baby son
after two doctors who cared for him he
later admitted he hadn't taken the virus
seriously enough today johnson wished
president trump and the first lady
a speedy recovery i think we all want to
send our best wishes to the president
and
the first lady and i've done that this
morning as you can imagine
and i'm sure that they'll both stage a
very strong
recovery well wishes too from russian
president vladimir putin who has been
following a strict work from home regime
mostly meeting people through video
conferences instead of in person
today putin sent trump a telegram saying
i am sure that your inherent vitality
good spirits and optimism will help you
cope
with the dangerous virus political
leaders here in canada have tested
positive two and back in march
prime minister justin trudeau spent two
weeks in quarantine after his wife
sophie gregoire trudeau was diagnosed
with the virus
today the trudeau sent well wishes to
the trumps
sophie and i both wish president trump
and first lady melania trump
a safe and speedy recovery they had
certainly reached out when sophie got
her diagnosis
earlier in the spring
and in canada the case numbers in parts
of this country are still worrying
in quebec more than 1 000 positive tests
were reported in the past 24 hours
that is the largest single day increase
since may 3rd
ontario is reporting a record high
number of new cases
732 today nova scotia is now reporting
one new case of covid19 it's connected
to travel outside the atlantic bubble
alberta has 122 new cases and bc
161. quebec's premier is warning more
restrictions
may be coming a partial lockdown is
already in place in three regions
including
montreal and quebec city and ontario is
introducing a number of stricter public
health measures
including a province-wide mass policy
the premier of ontario telling people to
keep their circles
tight abigail beeman reports
our health system is in crisis because
of the covert 19 pandemic
a stark message from ottawa public
health this system is nearly broken
the test swabs are waiting for analysis
they're sitting backlogged for over a
week
and dr vera etches national counterpart
is no more cheerful
dr teresa tam says they've been keeping
an eye on an increase in
hospitalizations and deaths
now at 10 a day she calls the curve's
momentum the opposite of a roller
coaster
the way up is fast and easy but the way
down is long and slow
and downward momentum can be stopped or
even reversed with any wrong step
you also need figuring out where to put
their feet
covered 19 slammed provinces ontario and
quebec
we need to reduce our social
contacts it's a question of life
or debt in quebec red zoned areas are
already under lockdown
but with more than a thousand new cases
friday
we might need to close other activities
in the coming days
we simplify it and and we work on these
hot
hot spots while in ontario the premier
announced new restrictions for
ottawa toronto and peel region there are
new patron caps for restaurants banquet
halls and gyms
for the whole province more mask rules
and starting sunday you won't see
long lines like these no more walk-ins
at testing centers
after two days to catch up on test
processing and reset
they'll reopen tuesday by appointment
only
what we're saying is keep the social
circles tight don't go out and have the
extended families of 20-25 people
meanwhile toronto's medical officer of
health wrote to the province
asking for much tougher restrictions for
her city
a ban on indoor dining indoor sports and
group
exercise classes and a ban on
non-essential trips outside the house
ford's announcement didn't go that far
yet an example of the push and pull
around pandemic restrictions donna okay
abigail beeman in ottawa thank you
anger and anguish coming up joyce
eshequan's husband on what his wife
endured and what he thinks of the
hospital
where she died
the family of joyce eshequan say they
intend to take legal action
as she lay in a quebec hospital eshequan
recorded a video
pleading for help and on it you can hear
hospital staff insulting and demeaning
her
today her husband said systemic racism
has contaminated that hospital
and killed his wife felicia perillo
reports in a warning
some viewers may find the video
disturbing
yeah in tears
hardly able to find his words joyce
eshequan's husband says
they killed my wife four days after the
37 year old died in a quebec
hospital her family has announced they
will be taking legal action
in the following weeks lawsuit against
the joliet hospital and their employees
will be filed
also we are the opinion that criminal
actions were
made by the hospital the mother of seven
from the etiquette community
died on monday at a joliet hospital in
disturbing circumstances
in her final moments eshequan managed to
record the insulting remarks hurled at
her
by hospital staff she had been admitted
for stomach pains a few days earlier
both a nurse and an orderly have been
fired and three investigations
are underway the family's lawyer says
they'll file complaints with police the
human rights commission
and with the quebec order of nurses
eshequan's death has sparked outrage
across the province
and calls for the government to act
against systemic racism
quebec premier francoise has called
eshequan's death
unacceptable and says he's committed to
making changes
but he has repeatedly denied the
existence of systemic racism
for me it's in relation with the
black people in the united states for a
reason we know
for me i don't see that in quebec
but for sure there is some
racism against the first nation
in quebec and i want to fight atticum
community leaders are demanding an
in-person meeting with the premier they
also stress the need for him to admit
that systemic racism exists
and says if he doesn't he's part of the
problem felicia pirillo global news
juliette quebec bnb conspiracy ahead an
innkeeper on trial
claims he's been helping u.s border
patrol
an american man accused of smuggling
people into canada now claims he's an
informant for
u.s immigration officials canadian
authorities charged robert boulet with
human smuggling last year
and revelations from a separate u.s
court case appear to show american
officials knew what he was up to
for years paul johnson explains
you couldn't have written a better
screenplay about the smugglers in
saga a man with a bed and breakfast
right on the border
and for years complaints about a
constant stream of people crossing his
property
from the u.s and into canada where are
you from
i can't speak last spring canadian
officials arrested smugglers in owner
robert boulet
and charged him with human smuggling
while that case is winding its way
through the courts
many wondered how his alleged business
was able to run for so
long in a place so heavily watched
particularly by the americans now
documents that have surfaced in an
unrelated court case in seattle
raise intriguing questions about that
in a pile of heavily blacked out u s
government papers
boule is reported as saying he has been
assisting the border patrol since about
2003
providing their intelligence unit with
information about his guests
which has resulted in numerous arrests
all of this under an arrangement boulez
said he had with the american border
authorities
the u.s border patrol says boule was not
their informant
but their sister agency ice declined to
comment
and said they don't talk about
informants there are a lot of questions
here
vancouver immigration lawyer richard
kirlin says if boulez's
arrangement was real the implications
are explosive
this is aiding and embedding a
conspiracy to violate canada's
immigration
system by an american intelligence
asset as for boule his american lawyer
told global news that neither he
nor boule can speak publicly about the
case
because of a court order obtained by the
very agencies
he claims to have collaborated with paul
johnson global news
vancouver next are there any takeaways
from president trump's diagnosis
2020 just keeps delivering now even the
american president has covid19
a 74 year old man who started the year
claiming the virus was
just like the flu who has repeatedly
said it's under control and who has
never been a strong advocate of wearing
masks
the commander-in-chief of the u.s now
has a potentially life-threatening virus
it should be a wake-up call plenty of
americans know the risks of covid19
more than 200 000 have died from it and
have listened to their president say
things
like this it's going to disappear one
day it's like a miracle it will
disappear
the faster we go back the better it's
going to be and then i see the
disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute one
minute
and is there a way we can do something
like that
by injection now trump has become
infected himself
the president whose secret service
details surrounds him with concentric
rings of security
could not be shielded from this
invisible enemy
british prime minister boris johnson
wasn't protected either
he's 18 years younger than trump and got
so sick with covid he ended up in
intensive care
and admits he was close to death the nhs
has saved my life no question things
could have gone either way it exposes a
basic truth about covid19
no one is immune there is no cure and
there is much we still don't know
about the virus the wise take it
seriously and observe public health
restrictions
getting it is for many a scary and
humbling experience
will it change president trump will he
survive
and if he does will he admonish those
who dismiss it
and refuse to wear masks the world is
left to wait and see how a silent enemy
that has altered all of our lives
will affect the future of america
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye